γνωρίσω τοσαμέρη καιρες άλλα πράγματα ίσωσμένεις πίσω που κάποια αλλά πέζειρολον και οη φίλησου οι
δύοσελικής εφυβικέ χρόνια οι φίλι ήταν πάντητα και αμε και ακόμα και ήταν δεν επίε
ναενακολουθοσατε βράδια έξω μαζί τους ξέρα τια πιο λόγο κανάς είναι επιστεκαιότιο κύρος ναγίνει τιώς
που έγινα ας πούμε αλλά έσεύουνταν το γι αυτόν υπάρχουν κι φίληέι φίλους το χώρο
ο αθριτισμόκάνες αρκετούς καιαρκετούσε στο εξωτερικό δ μπορώ να πωότι σε πολλές χώρες έχω κάποιον
άνθρωπο που ξέσεινα το πουπάρο τηλέφωνο να έρτεδο να έθελα νασεδώ να έρτει να μεδιε
και υπάρχουν και άλλες περιπτώσεις όπως για παράδημασουμε τν ιτλλώ των καμάρκοταμπέρι που είμαστε πάρα
πολλάκαλήφίλη μεφιλοξένησε στο χώρο του τν φιλοξένης αώ στην κύπρο κάνεις γνωρίμες γιατί μαατή τους
ανθρώπους στην ουσία μεγαλόνεις μαζί μεστο κήπετο είμαστε ναδκάλη τα διασταα άκριπος ότι τραβόγό τραβάτε
ζίνως ιτα προβλήματα πο περνά ο ίδιος ιτερο πάντων η κούραση που έχι έχω ότι
και εγώ την ίδια είμαστε φίλι έξω όπου το να γωνιστικό χώρον την ώραν του
αγώναμέσα είμαστε τα θέλασε κερτήσιο θα να με κερδήσεις πισόπλα τις μαχαιριές ο κύριάπος δεχθηκε
τ αξιδούσις μας νομίζωδεκτικαμε και νομίζω αχμα δε έχομε αλλά νομίζω μέσα στο κομμάτι της
κοινωνίας μας ποξέρεις πολλές φορέακού όου αθλητές το επιβέδο το δικούςπου φτάνουν σε ψηλών επιπεδώ
ότι το παράβονο τους είναι ότι ουλή θυμούντα τους μετά την επιτυχία σταροδρόμιο να υκάλουν
τη φωτογραφία να τουζόπουν την ανθοδέσμοι και μετά που λίο ξεχάνουν τους ένιωσες ότι έγινε
αυτό δηλαδιάτομα τα οποία μπορεί να ήρταν να βάλουν μια φογραφιτσα